what am i worth well i've got a few
assets
and to be honest more than a few debts
most people say that to calculate your
net worth
you should add up those assets and then
subtract those debts
but that really doesn't show the whole
picture
[Music]
the thought of having a net worth above
zero when you're just starting out maybe
you've got
student loans and very little income
might sound ridiculous and i understand
because
i'm very young and cool too
[Music]
but even if you don't have a lot of
money to invest you can still invest in
wait is it really that corny yeah
you can still invest in yourself or to
put it better
you can invest in your human capital
suzanne wooley of bloomberg wealth thank
you so much for being on good money
can you explain to me what human capital
is
human capital is basically our potential
you may feel
first starting out that you don't have a
lot of money maybe you have student debt
um you feel like you're not very rich in
assets
um but the fact is that here's another
corny line for you like you are your
biggest asset
you have years of earning potential so
you may not have a lot of money in the
bank
but your potential at that point is huge
um so you're actually rich in that
respect even though you may feel sort of
everyday poor can you explain to me the
ways
in which human and financial capital
sort of converge
as a lifetime goes by so when you just
start out
you have untapped human capital you have
huge earnings potential for decades and
decades
but you don't have a lot of financial
capital going through life
you are building your financial capital
you're also building your human capital
but say at age 55 or so
you may be in your peak earning years so
when you look out down the road
you know 20 30 years your earning
potential is not that huge but by this
point
you probably have a lot of financial
capital you've saved in your retirement
savings program
maybe you have other outside savings so
at this point your financial capital
might be a little bit ahead of your
human capital say
um and that's pretty much sort of as it
should be
so how can i invest in my human capital
what actions can i take to make the most
impact
[Music]
huh
your ability to earn an income is one of
your greatest assets
oh hi who are you
i'm marybeth stojahn i'm a certified
financial planner oh well thanks for
coming on the show
how is my career one of my biggest
assets that salary that you're bringing
in
the employer benefits there is so much
that can add to your net worth
over time which is why you need to
really nurture your career to make sure
you're
extracting everything you can out of it
what are some steps i can take to
nurture my career
the basic ones that we all know about
are those promotions
the salary increases and you know asking
for increased responsibility
at your job the big thing that was
misconstrued especially for young people
is
those only come around so often you can
actually drive that process as well
oftentimes many people are waiting to be
recognized you're waiting
for that annual review you're waiting
for your boss or somebody to recognize
your worth or the good things that
you're doing
and so the biggest thing that we can do
as young people is really take your
career by the reins and think and make a
plan for yourself
you want to communicate with your
certainty with your boss and your
supervisor to make sure you're clear
number one on what you can do to advance
your position in your role
you can set your own career growth goals
and really
you can drive that process of meeting
with your supervisor you might not get
that raise
every quarter every six months but you
can still have goals and check in to
make sure that you're clear of like or
how are you tracking are you doing the
right things
are you on track for the raise or the
promotion that you are seeking out
and and you're getting that feedback
line that feedback loop does not need to
be once a year the goals don't really
work if we're only checking in on them
once a year
so beyond those six-month check-ins and
making sure that i'm on the right track
what else can i do on my own time to
build my human capital so a couple
things one
i like to say focus on education so you
can sign up for online courses covering
any topic that you're interested in so
for example if you're marketing social
media marketing how to use industry
specific software
ways to improve your leadership skills
so there's ways that you can actually
round
out yourself as a manager and a leader
as well a lot of the times we're
focusing just
on like on the technical skills but
there's some software skills that we
need as managers and leaders in
advancing
the growth ladder another one is
checking in with your employer and if
they
they
fund or offer any uh continuing
education opportunities
will they actually pay for you to go and
take any of those
classes or courses to advance yourself
is another one
and then um certifications so depending
on your industry there's i'm sure a
variety of designations or specialties
or certifications that you can get
and you can seek those out on your own
so what if i feel stuck like i'm at a
dead end in my current job
if you're feeling stuck in your current
position at work one of the things that
i usually say is go back
and and take stock of like what are your
career growth goals
are you in an industry that you enjoy is
it something that you want to continue
to pursue
and i think the biggest thing is don't
be afraid to to jump
if you want to go in for one last push i
like to say build a career
um reverse bucket list what are all of
the things that you've accomplished in
your job
that you're currently in if you want to
go in for one last push or
kind of like conversation around
negotiating or growth and if it doesn't
work out
look for another job if you're feeling
stuck nobody says you have to stay
thanks so much mary beth for stopping by
so
hypothetically i get to the point in my
career where i can start investing some
actual financial capital
but how should i invest that based on
the type of career that i have
william bernstein bill thank you so much
for joining us on good money um could
you just
really quickly introduce yourself and
say what it is that you do
i'm a recovering neurologist i haven't
practiced for 15 years
i write about finance i write about
economic and technological uh history
i do have an investment advisory firm
that i uh
co-founded uh with a lady named susan
sharon official frontier advisors
uh and uh that's uh it in a nutshell i
guess
let me ask you based on their careers
what should people be thinking about how
they should invest their money
you have to ask yourself is your job uh
a um
a bond or is it a stock or a lottery
ticket how risky is your human capital
and so if your human capital is not very
risky if you're that tenured professor
uh or a government employee you can
afford to take lots of stock market risk
but if you're working in the financial
services industry uh
you're already invested your job is
already invested in the stock market
so maybe you want to take a lot less
risk in your investment portfolio
if you look at your total capital okay
your investment capital
plus your your human capital uh
when you're very young the the your
your your human capital overwhelms
your investment capital so there's
nothing wrong with taking a lot of risk
particularly if you have a relatively
secure job so if you have a job that's a
bond you have a nice
secure teaching position or government
position
or a reasonably secure job in your
industry with good employment prospects
no matter where you are
uh then essentially you have a lot of
bond capital
and you're in you're on the human side
so there's no reason why you can't go
whole
hot and invest all of your investment
capital when you're young
in stocks and at least the theory says
that's what you should do
the problem with that comes on the
emotional side
which is there are very few people
seeing very few sentient beings in this
quadrant of the galaxy
that can tolerate an all stock portfolio
when they're 25 years old
let's say that you have a more
freewheeling career
what kind of safe things should you be
putting your money in the classic
riskless asset
uh right is of course a t bill has no
it's perfectly
reasonably safe the government can
always print money uh
to to pay you to pay you back there's no
there's no credit
risk uh or almost no credit risk and
there's almost
no duration risk uh either
in terms of the last few decades what
has changed about
what jobs are bonds stocks
and and and has that gotten worse or
better i suppose oh
much worse uh you know um we're
we're living we're living in libertarian
heaven uh
right now where no one has you know
fewer and fewer people have
have job security i mean you're a
journalist i don't have to tell you
about that
so there are far fewer bond like jobs
out there
and a whole lot of jobs that are more
like really bad lottery tickets
yikes so maybe my career is more of a
lottery ticket
i hope it hits